[Music]
if you caught me news submitted by
barbell sandwich hmm Oh interesting
doesn't taste it how much does that mean
to powerlifters come in like sandwich
you the sexual position a crime writer
has been arrested in connection to for
cold case murder oh [ __ ] that only
happens in movies what the [ __ ] is the
method actor or a writer yeah it's like
saying like Stephen King got caught for
all those murders you dress it up like a
clown and killing kids and stuff yeah
crazy I see so the kids are leaving
YouTube comments I'd probably dress up
like a clown that's crazy huh yeah so
this award-winning Chinese writer he was
what Awards did he win I'm not sure
that's right yeah but he gave himself
most murder free author annually and is
this person writing for the here or for
the there okay yeah okay so he's a jerk
so he's the Chinese even King he's a
Czech even Chow there's already a
Stephen Chow Kyle's trying to figure out
it was like a me situation far like
Zing's Alice situation yeah so he's now
53 years old new is his name so he even
knew Lou Lou okay it's Steven Lou Lou
young Matt Bell that's Lou that's not
real words sounds about right to me
America let's go yeah so back in 1995 he
stayed at a hostel family owned hostel
with a friend of his so the student the
two of them stayed at this hostel it may
plan on robbing it and so when Bayard
wait they were staying there and they
were robbing the place that they were
staying at the author was staying there
yeah okay back in 1995 on my birthday
actually November 29
I turned the G yeah so sorry
on that day that's what they were
robbing male that was staying at that
hostel and so when he fought back they
ended up beating him to death and then
to cover up that crime they ended up
killing the owners the and their 13 year
old grandson oh so they killed four
people how did they kill him beating
them today
plenty Wow legend even a bludgeon you
think so these guys stories it's just
his real-life past experiences yeah what
you like was he like I should write a
book about this [ __ ] and then he became
like a really popular author and he's
like he's like a real nonfiction work
and it's fencing hey how about you make
it a fiction work he's like oh yeah
thank you very good boy like you don't
want to incriminate yourself hey where
would I be without you thank you I was
gonna name the main character Julio -
but I changed something just changes
control-f all that so it was like the
Chinese OJ Simpson yeah like the way
that they changed it if I did it the
word says right get it huge and then the
if is like very very small it's really
funny controlling what a piece of [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's the book it's a company I
think because they were pissed off or
they're trying to yeah they were working
with the Goldman Goldman that made them
do that yeah no no Jays fault once again
Oh didn't fit oh yeah with this guy
though he first started writing for a
magazine back in 1985 he ended up
getting into or he was published by the
writers publishing house which was
China's first major book publisher in
2005 he they published a novel with his
called a film and then you know so he
also did another novel a romance novel
that was published in 2014 which was
later adapted to become a fifth
episode TV show what the [ __ ] but then
the his most his most well-known works
was this book called the guilty secret
published in 2010 oh yeah that confesses
where it describes life from the
perspective of several poor farmers but
in that book in the preface he wrote
quote I want to create a novel about a
beautiful female writer who has killed
many people yet the cases remain
unsolved so he thinks he's a beautiful
female right no no he's a man this is a
girl in the story yeah no but he'll
never catch brilliance yeah but the cops
have been trying to solve this case for
like 22 years and then so they had read
reopened it recently a couple months ago
and thanks to like DNA science they were
able to trace like his fingers the most
basic [ __ ] that you do like those are
your first steps of like solving a
murder they just didn't have a
technology 20 years ago they're even
doing that here in the state's word
they're opening up old cases DNA testing
and then that's how they were able to
trace it down to this writer and his
friend and say they were both arrested
and when they arrested this writer in
his home he told the police I have been
waiting for you for a long time
what is [ __ ] he just sits there and he's
like you know he's sitting there in a
chair you know with a drink made
prepared for himself I wrote the whole
case hey I've been waiting for you for a
long time take two take two actually
what are you Denny I tell mr. Jenna I
said action yeah
come on language I've been waiting for
you for a long time
[Laughter]
[Music]
perfect portrayal yeah it always goes
back to Mexican look wants to be he's
gonna hate half of his son I woulda he's
gonna be doing my grass really well yeah
so when he was taken into custody
apparently he handed police a letter
that he wrote to his wife who he never
told about the murders and he ended up
saying like I can finally be free from
this mental torment I've endured for so
long come on poor guy had his llama kill
everyone
yeah the right books about it so much so
much stress so much money he made how do
we know he made much money we just know
he was an author I know plenty authors
who don't make [ __ ] dude but it was a
famous author and then they made in
China
everyone gets exploited I don't know
that they just take his work and then
pay him like 50 cents in a bowl of
noodles and then they make me regret
them only for factory workers yeah but
like you know IP doesn't exist in China
so they just stole everything just copy
all the [ __ ] and so on street corner
maybe the hostel owners were also bad
guys and he just kind of the 13 year old
was a bad guy really bad guy I know a
lot about 13-year old fashion most of
them are bad not to call any or output
them give me a name
Edward Meister for five one or whatever
like [ __ ] like that yeah you know
it's always feel like that though yeah
little kids can be [ __ ] so kind of thing
I'm gonna get in trouble
yes just think about it before you say
it
no don't why is it you could edit out
why do you support the murders wholesale
I'm done okay
so in another world where murder is kind
of okay right what
Jolyon so okay in another world it's
okay so imagine you're a fan of this
guy's work we all like Game of Thrones
yeah
you know so let's say george RR martin
was inspired by a trip that he took to
ireland and he saw some castles and he
had sex with a lady that said no to him
and he murdered some dragons and people
and he came back and he decided to write
his books and that was the inspiration
that made him write Game of Thrones
which made us so happy today so if
you're a die-hard fan and you go oh [ __ ]
well he had to do that to get that
content or we could ski hit zoom zoom in
a little bit on our real world we're
like Woody Allen has done some crazy-ass
[ __ ] and everyone gives them ovations
every year at the odds what are the
quizzes [ __ ] other than you like [ __ ]
his daughters adopted her and marry her
and then he raised her yeah [ __ ] me
marry me yeah she was like some thirteen
year old
asian girl or something or what she's
underage or Roman Polanski to be like
raped yeah like someone then he fled and
then like you know everyone's all like
poor Rome and like in Hollywood
especially like I know what's her name
the best actress ever
everyone loves her menstruation like
I've said many times it like whatever
the best so I'm just wondering like if
you're mother Teresa and you did this
much love or like this much you gave
this much happiness right but you also
do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but there's this
like support Michael Jackson you know
Michael Jackson didn't do anything wrong
though it's not the same what about the
Cosby
oh yeah Bill Cosby's nuts yeah he did a
lot of good they made people very happy
if you I'm so pissed about how much good
Bill Cosby does did he really do good he
did he like helped a lot of
african-american like low-income
families go to college and all that
stuff the groups like the n-double-a-cp
like that he did that yeah like he he
contributed like he contributed
to the community yeah and I don't know I
guess what you're trying to say is so
couple of chicks got raped along the way
he did a lot of good Outland it really
great know you yeah see I don't know
people might crucify me but all I'm
saying is if if someone did really good
in the world I don't know they can do a
little bit I think you can separate it
in our minds like okay this is their art
whatever they provided out to the world
and then this is the bad [ __ ] that they
did just separate it if we found out
James Cameron's touching on kids
Terminator 2 is still kicks ass how
about a high five for that yeah maybe
they should still do the time if they
get caught but at the same time maybe
their time shouldn't be as much because
they gave so much love to the world I'll
maybe give them a computer I don't know
I don't forgive anybody anybody well no
I do I forgive but I don't forget so
like if someone does something bad I
just only see the bad thing they did
okay so like let's say somebody that is
like Mother Teresa yeah give so much to
the world mm-hmm
awesome but she had a side hobby
kidnapping and killing people see there
are many people what did these people
could or bad random yeah it's Dexter
Isis or not it's not just a fight killer
it's like she kidnapped the kid and
stabbed them for fun we'll see in that
case I think it's unbalanced cuz the
amount of love that she's putting out
can't possibly be as overpoweringly and
overwhelmingly good as the amount of bad
she's doing one of these just three kids
but she she saved me Millions okay yeah
but like millions applies she fed and
saved I guess the question is how many
kids you gotta save where it's okay to
kill one key what's the balance
every 10 kids you can kill one kid zero
pretty reasonable whatever society
accepts the most as the answer I will
get these are the laws that they never
figure it out I think it's pretty
important actually yeah it's really just
a law of public perception because yeah
it's like this it's like it's like
there's a button right and then this
button will kill a million people or
save one kid but do I love the kid or
another kid just a kid that's different
though because now the situation is
completely changed does the kid call
things toxic and problematic regularly
cuz if so just hit the bottom I'm gonna
have to say no murder like just don't
know murder zero okay if you would like
set a bad thing one time like you said
the n-word when you were 13 or something
like that like you shouldn't have said
that and that's a battery you have to
donate to to erase that I'll make it
okay well that's not you didn't murder
anybody so it's still bad but you still
really bad yeah but like how many kids
you have to donate to where you can be
the okay and would say no yo you can't
say it again only rappers can do that
it's a big it yeah is there an amount of
money you could send it okay and would
say I think that's worth asking and how
about you answers in the comments right
now cuz I'd like some objective rules
cuz it gets confusing you know just be
good just be good I like that I've paid
into this a lot like and I'm Michael
hundred bucks off and they're like hey
you can't you still can't say the n-word
you need to do a little bit more ya know
if he is for the stuff exactly can I buy
a platinum pass
yeah we're I pay a lump sum now and then
I got like I got it for life you get all
the benefits I need to know all the
stuff that's true
what up all my positive people I want to
hear your thoughts put it in the
comments below because if you're
negative shut the hell up and go drink
some raid please but if you're very
positive leave it in the comments below
for the last video over here
[Music]